Ryan is with us in Denver hi Ryan how
are you good day thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up well I week my wife and I
just got started on your plan in
December so we built up our emergency
fund and then had a couple of hours at
sea so we depleted it and we were trying
to build that back up and I got a
settlement offer from one of my credit
cards who I owe almost eleven thousand
five hundred dollars to to settle for
30% of that so they're offering to
settle for three thousand four hundred
and sixty-five excellent um my problem
is I don't have that money and my debt
negotiator that I had hired before I got
on with your plan told me that I should
do whatever I can to get that because
that's the best offer I'm going to get
nice to do whatever possible to get that
money together that has to be paid to
them by tomorrow so I don't know what
your recommendation on that would be my
brother has American Express card that
would have to be paid off within a month
was the pretty hard for me I've got a
couple of trucks I could sell or kind of
Junkers I don't know anything on them
but they're not in really good shape I
just have to pay him back within a month
I don't know if that's something you
would recommend doing know her or not I
would never do that
borrow on your brothers American Express
card and it's sweet of him to offer but
he's foolish yeah to offer to put his
own head on the chopping block like that
that's silly
no no absolutely a bad idea it's got bad
chemistry all over it you know it don't
you
yeah and I just I don't want to do
something you here's the deal your debt
guy is full of crap and your debt guy
you need to be aware of does he get paid
when he settles something only no I paid
them up front god help you okay well I
can deal well they're just all about
jacking things around and all this kind
of stuff now if you have room on another
credit card that you can borrow money
and you're borrowing money to pay off
borrowed money at 30 cents on the dollar
yeah I would do that but I would not
borrow from your brother's AMEX card no
way no how and guess what if they made
you this offer you can get the same
offer in two or three months when you
scratch the money
they still want money right just keep
the car if you got a copy of the offer
in writing yeah they sent me a letter I
received on Friday great and they gave
you three days pretty much they gave me
until tomorrow
yeah so here's that idea I'll be happy
to accept the offer but I need 30 days
okay and if you can give me 30 days fine
if not you're gonna get no money until
you give me the same offer again I've
been I hadn't worried about them or
anything so we're following their plan
yeah follow the plan and get make sure
you keep a thousand dollars in the bank
at all times minimum as your starter
emergency fund and you settle with these
people over and above that money you
scratch together over and above that but
what this does do is it does shock the
system of your life and it makes you go
okay if I kept my freaking act together
and I get rid of junk trucks and I
really start scratching and saving I'm
really going to be able to do this right
now you can't do it by tomorrow not
unless you do something insane yeah and
I didn't want to have to borrow from
family to pay off a credit card that's
it that's under the Insane column yeah
it's so do you do you have the ability
to borrow the money off another card or
something like that you're selling nurse
nope everything else was either maxed
out or one into collections because of a
divorce everything that I went through a
couple of years ago then what I would do
is send a counteroffer to their proposal
that says in 30 days I think I can do
this or in 60 days I think I can do this
so if you'll give me a 60 day window I
will accept your offer otherwise I can't
but the your debt the offer is
acceptable the deadline is not okay
there's no one there's no rule that says
you can't continue the negotiation okay
because they like they like keeping the
file open they like the fact that you're
talking to them as this being done
through the debt negotiator are you
doing it yourself I've been going to
that that negotiator and they've been
talking to the collector for me okay and
then you need to explain that to the
debt negotiator that I'm not going to do
insane things I'm going to work through
this on a systematic process driven
basis that is wise and don't ask me to
do insane things again
I agree that if you could scrape the
money together take the deal but I
didn't hear anything that says you can
scrape the money together except under
the insane column
yeah there's no I can get it by tomorrow
without telling us that I didn't want to
do in the first place
exactly so we're not going to switch bad
credit card debt for payday lender if I
just don't do that stuff you can see see
the difference in the feeling in your
stomach now that we're talking about it
versus when you were talking to that guy
yeah that's what I want you to stick
with that sense of I'm going to win but
I'm going to win like the river beats
the rock just over time the rock becomes
smooth because the river never quits and
that's why you're going to win but it's
not because you just jump around and go
one insane thing to another insane thing
right and so walk your way through it
you'll be fine keep negotiating with
them so go back to your debt guy and say
don't bring me any more insane things
but I'd like to counteroffer with 60
days I'll be happy to accept this offer
well you can't do as I can and if you
don't want to do it I'll be happy to do
it and that's what I paid you for though
so paid you a lot upfront by the way so
freaking do your job and then you guys
get your act together scratch that money
up and knock this debt out and have a
garage sale take an extra job during
that 30 days at 60 days and let's let's
take advantage of these of this great
offer because it is a great offer the
the amount is the timeframe is untenable
you